vous avez été condamné pour proxénétisme
aggravé
suite au scandale zahia qui a secoué le
monde du football en 2010 alors c'est
grâce aux témoignages inédits d'une
escort girl cas boussofiane désespéré
obtenir la révision du procès puisque
sarrail nes corps de garde
âgé de 49 ans a déclaré que c'est
l'homme d'affaires suisse il vous vié
qui aurait été à l'origine des relations
sexuelles tarifées de zahia et pas vous
alors c'est du ce copain avec zahia en
fait alors non en fait oui bien sûr
c'était mon ami déjà d'une part mais ce
témoignage pour moi est très important
cyril parce que ça fait dix ans que
j'attends ce moment là j'ai toujours
clamé mon innocence parce que mon seul
ma soeur est rare aujourd'hui c'est
enfin à l'époque c'était d'être l'ami de
zahia d'organiser des soirées cabinet
met son oreille comme tout le monde
continuera les soirées parce qu'on veut
savoir bien organisé les soirées dans
les boîtes que tout le monde connaît sur
les champs-elysées et donc c'est pas des
soirées intimes président aurait dit ou
non du toit non c'était justement on en
reviendra sur pour rebondir sous - sur
la libertine non ces soirées que des
boîtes de nuit très connue des
champs-elysées et commença comme ça se
passe de partout tu viens ben tiens ta
copine elle est mignonne s'installe à la
table bonjour après comme j'ai toujours
dit ça ya c'est pas ma soeur c'est pas
ma femme elle fait ce qu'elle veut après
salon d'hiver acquis qu'elle veut
maintenant aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
heureux parce que j'ai reçu un coup de
fil il ya quelques jours et c'était pour
moi j'habite à marrakech maintenant donc
on m'appelle je me réveille à 9 heures
du matin je reçois pas le message on me
dit oui voilà il ya quelque chose qui se
passe c'est un nouveau témoignage qui
est eux qui me dédouane totalement
puisque en fait à l'époque on m'a accusé
d'être le proxénète de zahia à une
période où je n'avais pas vu ça y est
c'est à dire que les monts les faits ont
éclaté en avril 2010 et moi j'ai
toujours dit que zahia je n'avais pas de
contacts et capte puis un enfer depuis
le printemps 2009 paraît que ça si vous
avez tout perdu suite à cette affaire
ben j'ai perdu et c'est simple j'ai
perdu mon travail d'ailleurs à l'époque
j'étais un petit animateur de télé
j'avais je venais de sortir un film j'ai
perdu aussi je devais me marier l'été
2010 j'ai perdu
bah oui ma future femme peut-être la
mère de mes enfants aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas j'ai perdu si l'essentiel de
mes rêves j'ai perdu mes nerfs familiaux
j'ai perdu beaucoup de choses donc on
vous a accusé d'être le proxénète de
zahia mais rien mais rien à voir vous
vous n'avez jamais fait de voilà de
proxénétisme pas du tout où cyril à
l'époque j'étais animateur délai à
l'image était jamais vous avez été
condamné pour ça j'ai été condamné et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je suis
très content parce que le témoignage de
cette de cette demoiselle que je connais
pas d'ailleurs les juniors et j'en
remercie c'est que elle elle donne des
faits elle donne des preuves des vidéos
elle donne des photos à dun ddd adresse
elle donne des noms de gens très connus
parce qu'il y avait réellement réseau et
surtout c'est qu'on m'avait reproché à
l'époque de du printemps 2009 à
printemps 2010 des agents procèdent de
zahia alors que je n'avais jamais vu
d'ailleurs j'étais sur écoute moi même
pendant six à huit mois il ya au quine
aucune conversation avait été condamné
alors justement alors c'est pour ça que
cette affaire c'était vraiment un fiasco
juridique pourquoi parce que au moment
des faits d'ailleurs on accuser à tort
deux joueurs de foot franck ribéry et
karim benzema karim et d'où le fiasco
ils ont été relaxés pour la simple et
bonne raison que karim benzema a
toujours nié les faits et d'ailleurs on
a eu la preuve que au final il n'a
jamais couché lequel elle a menti
franck ribéry effectivement avoué mais
elle a toujours menti sur son âge alors
ce qui est très important justement sur
ce dossier là c'est que l'escort girl
qui a témoigné donne des des adresses et
surtout des voyages des voyages très
précis entre printemps 2009 et printemps
2010 où son compagnon sans citer son nom
lui-même avait pris un billet d'avion
donc il savait pertinemment l'âge de
zahia alors que tout le monde elle a
menti à tout le monde sauf sauf à lui
qui était qui était au courant